lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
practicar el elevar al cuadrado binomios
esto es algo que hemos hecho antes pero
ahora lo haremos usando expresiones más
elaboradas comencemos con un repaso si
les pregunto a qué es igual a más b al
cuadrado que me responde bien pausa en
el vídeo y tratan de resolverlo por su
cuenta varios de ustedes quizás ya sepan
a que es igual un binomio al cuadrado
como este pero vamos a resolverlo paso a
paso esto es lo mismo que a más ve por a
más ve y multiplicamos está por esta
otra lo que da a cuadrada luego
multiplicamos esta por esta vez y queda
ave después multiplicamos esta vez por
esta y queda vea aunque también podemos
escribir como ave escribimos ave de
nuevo y finalmente multiplicamos esta
vez por esta otra vez de manera que
queda de cuadrada aquí lo que hice fue
aplicar la propiedad distributiva dos
veces lo que vimos detalladamente en
vídeos anteriores
las personas se refieren a esto como
binomio cuadrado perfecto de cualquier
forma ustedes deben estar familiarizados
con esto en esta revisión y si no lo
están los invito a que revisen esos
vídeos introductorios esto se simplifica
como a cuadrada más ave y otra ave si la
sumamos es 2 ave más b cuadrada porque
hicimos este repaso porque ahora podemos
usar esta idea de que a más b al
cuadrado es igual a a cuadrada más 2 ave
más b cuadrada para resolver cosas que
lucen un poco más elaboradas
ahora les pregunto cuánto es 5x a la 64
al cuadrado pausa en el vídeo traten de
calcularlo y tengan en mente esto y esto
hay varias formas de resolverlo pueden
expandir esto como lo hicimos aquí
arriba o pueden reconocer este patrón
que acabamos de establecer si tenemos a
más b al cuadrado el resultado va a ser
igual a esto
quizá noten que el papel de a lo tiene 5
x a la 6 y el papel debe lo tiene este 4
podemos decir que esto es igual a a
cuadrada sustituimos a por 5 x a las 6 y
5 x a las 6 al cuadrado es 25 x x a la
luego sumamos 2a b 2 x 5 x a la 6 x 4
vamos a escribirlo para no confundirnos
vamos a asignarle colores también 2 x 5
x a la 6 x 4 + b cuadrada + 4 al
cuadrado es más 16 podemos simplificar
esto es igual a 25 x x a la 12 más 2 x 5
x 4 es 42 x 50 10 x 4 es 40 más 40 x a
las 6 + 16
hagamos otro ejemplo el cual haremos más
rápido porque nos estamos volviendo
hábiles en esto
que queremos determinar a qué es igual 3
t cuadrada menos 7 a las 6 al cuadrado
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
ahora vamos a resolverlo juntos
esta es la a y esta es la vez que
tenemos que ver como -7 porte a las 6 ya
que esto es más b por lo que podemos ver
esto otro como más menos 7 a las 6
incluso podemos escribirlo si queremos
para que nos ayude a recordar que todo
esto es b todo esto va a ser igual a a
cuadrada que es 9 deporte a la cuarta
más 2 por esto por esto dos por a o por
b dos por tres de cuadrada es 6 de
cuadrada por menos 7 a la 6
mejor lo escribimos ya que hacerlo
mentalmente es un poco complicado
esto es más dos por tres de al cuadrado
por menos 7 t a las 6 y por último
sumamos el cuadrado de menos 76 menos
siete al cuadrado es 49 positivo y t a
las 6 al cuadrado este a la 12
esto es igual a 9 por t a la cuarta y
dos por 36 por menos 7 es menos 42 y te
cuadrada aporte a las 6 es sumamos los
exponentes porque tenemos la misma base
por lo que quédate a la 8 y luego
tenemos más 49 d a la 12 pareciera que
hicimos algo muy sofisticado al tener
este polinomio de grado mayor ya que
elevamos al cuadrado este polinomio con
términos de mayor grado pero en realidad
lo que hicimos fue aplicar la misma idea
que aprendimos hace unos vídeos o
lecciones anteriores solamente en
términos de elevar al cuadrado binomios